der pitztaler gletscher in tirol ein
meter schnee liegt hier bereits schon
anfang november beginnt die saison
lifte und seilbahnen laufen auf
hochtouren
der gletscher ist der höchste in tirol
viele besucher kommen nicht nur zum
skifahren und snowboarden sondern auch
für den ausblick
seit diesem monat können sie das
bergpanorama im warmen mit kaffee und
kuchen genießen
dreieinhalbtausend meter über dem
meeresspiegel dieser österreichische
architekt hat das ambitionierte projekt
betreut
architektonisches besondere an dem
gebäude dass wir versucht haben die
formensprache der bergwelt aufzunehmen
formen zu finden die ohnehin hier
vorkommen schneeverwehungen und
ähnliches und dass sich das gebäude
dadurch sehr schön in die bergwelt und
in die gletscherwelt integriert eine
besonderheit die freischwebende terrasse
mit einer 25 meter langen glasfront
geschwungene linien und verspiegelte
fassaden dominieren
der bau war eine logistische
herausforderung wir haben hier sie mit
wenig platz am baufeld selber zur
verfügung gehabt das heißt sämtliche
materialtransporte müssen sehr genau
geplant und koordiniert werden
alles muss ja erst aus dem tal hier auf
auf dreieinhalb tausend meter geschafft
werden
und das so anzuliefern das dann auch
rechtzeitig auf der baustelle ist und
dazu keinen verzögerungen kommt das ist
sicher dass die größte herausforderung
gewesen
drei jahre vergingen vom ersten entwurf
bis zum beginn der bauarbeiten
dann brauchten die arbeiter nur fünf
monate um aus österreichs
höchstgelegener baustelle österreichs
höchstgelegenes kaffee zu machen anfang
november eröffnete gemeinsam mit der
neuen wird spitz bahn
sie ist eine der modernsten seilbahnen
der alten inklusive sitzheizung 20
millionen euro hat das projekt insgesamt
gekostet
das café bietet platz für 100 gäste die
ausstattung traditionelle berghütten
atmosphäre mit viel eichenholz aber
modernen interpretiert
ok
neben kaffee serviert das kaffee torten
und kuchen aus der hauseigenen
konditorei die höhe wird
wir haben auch die komplikationen mit
der dünne luft kaffeemaschinen
einstellungen sind bei uns sehr sehr
wichtig ist sehr sensibel und voll wir
haben viele probleme mit milchschaum
erzeugung mit den mit den druckraum
beziehungsweise bier ausschenkt also ist
er oben auf dieser höhe einfach nicht
vielleicht zu arbeiten dass wir neben
snowboardern und skifahrern kommen seit
der eröffnung des cafés auch
tagesausflügler hoch auf den gletscher
einfach nur um das panorama zu genießen
das geld dazu dass dieses spiel ein dazu
das ist das highlight jeder der hierher
kommt muss hier hoch waren und sich das
café einmal anschauen den wunderbaren
ausbau panorama einzigartig
es ist perfekt man hat einen sehr guten
ausblick und wir können etwas leckeres
essen einfach super sonic in diesen und
cappuccino und standard gericht in
österreich
vom café aus führt eine piste direkt ins
tal war lässt sich die sachertorte dann
wieder abtrainieren